make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing our videos on the
Justice League one of the things that I
realized going back in and looking at
the videos we've done is that we never
covered at issue number 18 which is one
of the Legion of Doom tie-ins one of the
things to keep in mind for those you
guys who were new the Legion of Doom to
high ends really focus on of course the
Legion of Doom itself but they basically
take place outside of whatever's going
on in the Justice League story so it's
really kind of its own self-contained
series of events which is cool because
honestly you could read everything
that's been going on and Justice League
so far and then read Legion of Doom
later on or at least read the totality
and then read Legion of Doom later on
you kind of have to understand totality
in order to in order to grasp Legion of
Doom go for this comic there's a little
bit of explanation that we need to do
here in order to make it make sense and
the reason why is because this just
basically picks up with Lex Luthor
essentially tapping into the mental
remains or I guess though the physical
remains and the mind of Brainiac now the
Brainiac has a lot of different versions
that exist over the course of DC Comics
Rather's Brainiac for Brainiac five
there's the original vorld ox from back
in the day this is basically the
original one right like vril dox one and
that's what you want to call it the way
it was done in totality was actually
changing things up a bit the reason why
was because the original Brainiac was
pre-crisis rights Lewis it was kind of a
chance for Scott Snyder to sort of do
what he wanted to with the concept but
the idea was that much like the original
Brainiac this one was a collector of
worlds right you know kind of this
retelling of the story the Brainiac was
a collector of world who would just
travel around and literally correct
collect like planets and things like
that
and in fact after the events of totality
we kind of saw that sort of play out in
Justice League Odyssey right we're like
all these worlds were kind of freed and
then the the guardians of the universe
and the Green Lantern Corps basically
quarantined them off so nobody could get
in nobody could get out and then that
dealt with Darkseid and all that kind of
cool stuff but the idea here is that
this version of Brainiac had essentially
been killed now in truth this story of
the totality and all the things that go
into it the Titans and all that kind of
good stuff that's really too much to
cover and like a quick little intro
spiel so I invite you to check out the
video you'll find a link down in the
description which will explain the whole
thing to you but the overall gist of it
was that basically this version of
Brainiac was his body was physically
dead but his mind was not and the reason
why this matters is because while
Brainiac has historically been a pretty
cool member and a pretty significant
member of the Legion of Doom the
important thing to bear in mind here is
that for what Lex Luthor's doing which
is to say gaining as much information as
he can about this artifact of the
totality in order to truly understand
what's going on he needs someone like
Brainiac and the reason
why is because Brainiac had been around
for so long and he had explored so much
of the universe there's a lot of
knowledge there there's a lot of
information there and so in order to
basically use him we're not really
Euston but in order to gain access to
that information and to have it benefit
the the schemes of Lex Luthor and to
have Brainiac join the Legion of Doom
the idea is to bring him back and the
only way to really do that is to hook
the two of them up mentally and this is
a very dangerous game because remember
Brainiac is a 12th level intellect so
stepping into that mind is stepping into
a higher echelon of intelligence today
would seem Lex Luthor wouldn't really be
prepared for it but that's one of the
things that scott snyder really sort of
toys with here is that Lex Luthor is
usually considered to be like one of the
smartest men on the face of the earth
and so because of that it's very
difficult to like demonstrate
intelligence right like super-strength
you can demonstrate that easily like
Superman like punches an asteroid or
something like that it's difficult to
demonstrate intelligence and it's
actually done extremely well here but it
really requires context it requires you
to know how smart Brainiac is but with
Lex Luthor basically diving into his
mind and Brainiac saying like welcome to
this world I'm going to take over your
body and I'm going to go forward and do
villainous things Lex Luthor immediately
plays it smart and that's why I say he's
so he's he's crazy intelligent is he on
the same level as Brainiac
well of course not I mean the nature of
Brainiac is to be that smart this just
be smarter than like every being in
existence but what Lex Luthor lacks here
in intelligence come in comparison to
Brainiac he makes up for with guile
stealth and manipulation and that's what
the reasons why deluxe Luthor is such a
cool character because there's always a
way for him to essentially win right so
like Amy evil Batman more or less is
always a way for him to use his mind to
win but in this conversation with with
Brainiac what Lex really does is play on
the idea of there are things about this
universe that you're not totally
familiar with and as a man or as a being
who fancies himself on being an explorer
and learning all things that are there I
got a text on comic story it's important
that you understand that we have to work
together in this and so what I'm going
to do here is essentially spill the
beans about everything or at least about
this little piece of the totality and
how it ties into the bigger picture
which is kind of cool because this
doorknob that Lex Luthor carries around
has not been like full-on totally
explained by Scott Snyder it's just
there's this chunk of totality which has
been careening through the universe and
it's basically crashed on earth and like
it's a means by which perpetual is going
to come back and that's it that's really
all we ever really got and then like we
had this little doorknob and we didn't
really know how the store not fit into
the
and scheme of things outside of the fact
that like it's somehow synonymous with
the totality and so kind of jumping back
about forty or forty six thousand years
in the in the past as Lex Luthor tells
this story of to Brainiac what we end up
doing is picking up with Vandal Savage
now there's a reason why Scott's matter
does this a lot of what Snyder has done
has centered around Vandal Savage right
like Dionysian the chemical that Joker
consumes that Ra's al Ghul consumes that
kind of grants them immortality or at
least as long as they consume it it
grants him immortality Vandal Savage was
the first he was the first one to
consume the perfect version of Dionysia
and gain actual immortality meaning he
couldn't really be killed by a by like
disease or age or anything like that but
he could be killed by other by like
having his head chopped off or something
along those lines but with Vandal Savage
remember he was really kind of like the
rise like the first intelligent being
out there right because in his early
days he came into contact with a meteor
the meteor basically enhanced his
intelligence with Grodd him way beyond
man as it existed at the time which
allowed him to kind of go forward as
essentially a conqueror right and it's
one of the things that's talked about
here bye-bye lex luthor's it's somewhere
along the line this little fragment this
doorknob essentially as it is our
releases has been turned into crashed on
earth in the form of like a small little
piece of meteor but when it came to
Vandal Savage he coveted power above all
else and so instead of taking this
device and then in turn studying it and
then kind of spreading it around the
world he kept it to himself
and so as he did that he basically
traveled around the world and basically
you know he came across all these
various intellect see various people
from different points in time all of
whom were able to offer some tidbits of
information or insight on what this
piece of rock was and the reality was
that of course as it was kind of
reshaped and remoulded to essentially
fit like a more modern depiction which
of course ended up being in the form of
a doorknob
what Vandal Savage did is whenever
anybody discovers something new about it
he would not tell them what had already
been discovered instead he would keep
that information to himself that way he
was the only one that had the full brunt
of information regarding what this
doorknob is and how it relates to the
totality and the origin of the universe
and all that kind of good stuff and so
as time progressed eventually he
basically came upon a man named Lionel
Luthor now this is a very big deal and
the reason why is because Lionel Luthor
as he'd been depicted of course as a
father of Lex and his sister Lena was
basically a guy who was by all standards
of measurement a failure like he never
really left Kansas never really done
anything with his life could be the crap
out of his kids because they were
smarter than him I mean the guy had all
kinds of different problems what Scott
Steiner does here is come back and
change it all he basically wrecked Hans
everything and what he says is that
working alongside Vandal Savage that
Lionel Luthor was actually a genius he
was super intelligent now something that
I want to clarify here and the reason
why Scott Snyder can do this is because
when it came to the character of Lionel
Luthor in the new 52 landscape he didn't
show up until 2017 until superwoman
number 8 I think it was when you got
like the whole history between Lena and
and Lex and like all that kind of or
least the history was built on and then
Lionel was basically brought in before
that he was pre new 52 so he showed up
basically after crisis on Infinite
Earths and he was again like a total
failure so again uh Scott Snyder can
basically go through and do all this
because he can kind of provide like this
this backstory that we didn't really
have before did we didn't really know
about when it came to his character and
that's one of the important things is
that by studying this artifact he
basically learned a huge amount of
information about the universe now this
is something that that that Snyder
doesn't really seem to explain in the
sense of like how this works we don't
really know if the information that
Lionel Luthor gained from his artifact
is a result of the fact that it had been
traveling across the universe for so
long and had essentially like reached
earth after like a huge amount of time
and passed and all this information was
imprinted as if it had just seen
everything or if these things about the
universe were just ingrained as part of
its inherent knowledge that's not really
given to us and in reality it doesn't
really matter the only thing that really
matters is that we have this information
now and we can got to go forward
accordingly but it was Lionel Luthor who
discovered the still force it was Lionel
Luthor who discovered like the emotional
spectrum are not really discovered but
realized the emotional spectrum exists
and the guardians of the universe are
tapping into it and using it to create
the Green Lantern Corps it was Lionel
Luthor who discovered all these
different concepts and all these
different things a lot of the
information that that Scott Snyder's
been building on and been using as part
of his Justice League run this new
information for existing information
right so like the events of the war with
Atlantis the whole like crazy conflict
with the Dark Gods and all I kind of get
stuff all those things were basically
built on or at least discovered by
Lionel Luthor somewhere along the line
he was very much a pioneer in that
regard now the cool thing about this is
that he also sort of builds on the story
between Lex Luthor and and Martian
Manhunter which I'm not a hundred
percent sure that we covered what we end
up learning here is that Lionel Luthor
basically discovered that like Martians
exist on Mars so there's like
extraterrestrial life and so in an
effort to understand how they work and
what potential can be gained for
Humanity he in turn started using dr.
Earle who was originally the guy who
discovered Martian Manhunter
and the really
the old 1950s 1960s DC Comics and then
basically had him start kidnapping
Martians and bringing them in which is
how Martian Manhunter ended up on earth
in the DC Universe as part of like this
retold origin that DC release a little
while ago and so as a result of that Lex
Luthor of course basically helped
Martian Manhunter to escape but all
these things route back to Lionel Luthor
he's a huge reason for why a lot of this
information exists out there the problem
is that with a lot of the things that he
was doing especially performing
experiments on Martians and white
Martians and so on and so forth
what this led into was Vandal Savage
discovering everything that he was doing
and that's when Vandal Savage basically
confronted him and said like why are you
doing all this and that's when it dawns
on Lionel Luthor that Vandal Savage
doesn't understand everything he doesn't
grasp everything for all the haughtiness
as he puts on all the glitz and glamour
in reality the totality fragment won't
show him anything and so Lionel Luthor
is really the only one who can actually
see what's you know see what the bigger
picture is what this means and to kind
of explain this a little bit further
what this means is that for for Vandal
Savage all he can do is see the
different pieces people have gained and
then put those pieces together Lionel
Luthor can actually see all the pieces
they've gained and what the full picture
should be on its base level right so
like he truly understands what's going
on here all Vandal Savage knows is what
he's been told and so that's kind of the
cool thing it's kind of the cool little
revelation because in response to all
this Vandal Savage turns this guy's life
upside down and what he says is like as
far as the world is going to be
concerned we're going to change you
we're going to modify you're not gonna
have you know any real recollection or
anything as far as a world is going to
be concerned you're gonna be a failure
of a man who lived in Kansas and so
basically it explains why Lionel Luthor
appeared the way he did back in the days
before the new 52 so it works
exceedingly well this is a perfect
example of what DC's rebirth Charter was
right like blending everything that
worked with the new 52 with everything
that worked before the new 52 combining
these two elements together and
basically creating a cohesive DC
universe going forward it's awesome
aniseh is a genius idea and so that's
when we kind of pick up with a part of
the story worse like yes Lionel Luthor
was essentially essentially a failure he
was a drunk he'd never really seemed to
amount to anything as part as far as the
people in Smallville were concerned the
guy never really did anything with his
life and so that's when Lex sits down
with with Brainiac and says like this is
what we've learned from the totality
fragment but you have so much more
knowledge about the universe itself if
we can bind what we've learned so far
with everything you know then
have a whole new breadth of knowledge
that we didn't have before you guys
understand why Brainiac is so essential
for the plans of Lex Luthor but also why
Brainiac is such a valuable asset for
anybody who's trying to understand the
nature of the universe because he's
pretty much toured it all and so it's a
very it's a very cool concept because in
turn where Brainiac intended to turn on
on Lex and then like take over his body
instead Lucky's argument is remove your
emotional barriers right like stop
thinking so logically start thinking
emotionally become essentially more
human or at least more organic and less
computer and then like we'll go forward
from there and brainiacs sides with it
and Brainiac says yes then we will do
that like I will do that with you of
course we're also is also revealed they
have the remains of Perpetua which is
kind of a big thing but it's like join
our cause become a part of us and
together like we can usher in a whole
new level of power a whole new era now
this is big and this is important
because traditionally the Legion of Doom
has always just kind of been like
pennies nothing is like grandiose and
cosmic in scope is this the closest we
ever got was like Infinite Crisis was
like you know the multiple worlds and
things like that and that wasn't even
really Lex Luthor that was Alexander
Luthor from a different universe so it's
cool to see this happen because it
really sort of builds up the Legion of
Doom on like this huge cosmic scale and
makes them a lot more dangerous and a
lot more interesting than they've ever
been before but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come as
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]